Herkese merhaba sanatkar ve zanaatkar
Benim üç buçuk yıl önce reklam
profesyonelleri için hazırladığım bir
sorumluluk ve çeşitli noktalarında
Aslında mesleği göndermeler var ama
cevapladığı soru evrensel bir soru
dolayısıyla da aslında şu anda takip
eden herkese az ya da çok
ilgilendirdiğini düşünüyor musun bu da
şu ha yırtıcı olabilir miyiz bu basit
bir soru ve bu sorunu Nancy kadar basit
bir cevabı var O da evet olabiliriz
Google a girip İngilizce yaratıcılığını
nasıl arttırabilirim diye sorduğunuzda
134 milyon yanıtı ulaşıyorsunuz bu o
zaman ait bir akım şu anda 200 milyon
geçiyor diye düşünüyorum öne ve buraya
girdiğimizde gördüğünüz başlıklar arama
sonuçları genelde şöyle işte
yaratıcılığı arttırmanın 5 yolu
yaratıcılığı ateşlemenin 7 metodu uçtu
15 ipucu filan
Evet şimdi ben bu aramanın ilk 10
sayfasındaki bütün Sonuçları tek tek
tıkla alıp neredeyse istisnasız hepsinin
altında da yaratıcılığı arttırmaya dair
ufak tefek yöntemler gördüm bunlardan
birkaçını Şimdi sizinle paylaşmak
istiyorum mesela yöntemlerinden bir duş
almak bir tanesi mavilere diyebilmek bir
tanesi bira içmek bir tanesi sıkıcı bir
şey yapmak yaban mersini yemek bebeğini
Neyi ziyaret etmek sıradaki ikiyi ikinci
çok seviyorum sevişmek qveen edilmek
Yani bugün birisini aslında ya kalksanız
başarılı olsanız da olmasanız da en
azından biliyorsunuz ki yaratıcılığınıza
kaşık tabi bunlara baktığımızda şunu
hissediyoruz hepsi biraz yüzeysel
gidiyor ama hepsinin altında orta
o sayılmaz o Varsayım ne şu belli bir
yaratıcı potansiyelimiz var ve biz bunun
altındayız ve bu yöntemleri kullanarak
Oo gerçek potansiyelimizi yaşayabiliriz
işte Böyle olunca da Daha yaratıcı
olabilir miyim ben biraz daha karmaşık
bir soru çıkıyor karşımıza O da şu Neden
o kadar yani olabileceğimiz kadar
yaratıcı değiliz e dediğim gibi bu daha
karmaşık bir sonu cevabının biraz daha
dolan başla 20'li yaşlarında tazecik bir
reklam yazabiliyor yöneticilerin gözünde
yetenekleri geleceği olan bir reklamcı
ama ortaya sıradışı insanların dikkatini
çekecek herhangi bir şey de açıkçası
boyamıştım eş zamanlı olarak da bazı
kişisel problemler yaşıyoruz nedir bu
endişe nöbetleri eve Burada gördüğünüz
ilaçlar o sırada pek ajanstaki
çekmecemden eksik olmayan ilaçları işte
bir tanesi sakinleştirici bir
bir şurup bir tanesi mide asidini
önleyici bir Çiğneme tableti de bir
tanesinde zanaks yeşil reçeteli bir
sakinleştirici Ben bunu almadım uçağa
binemiyor dum bir süre Ben böyle
yaşayabilirim diye düşündüm Sonra fark
ettim ki korkunun alanı genişliyor etki
çeviriyor zamanda dedim ki galiba
profesyonel yargılı olmam lazım
araştırdım bir terapistin ismini buldum
randevu aldım Gittim kapıdan çevirmiş
öyle bir şey yani gündür metreye beş
metreyi O da dört duvar ucu kitaplarla
dolu Yare ve eski tahta zemin üzerinde
eski bir halı onun üstünde eski bir
çalışma masası önünde eski koltuklar ve
masanın arkasında da 50-60 yaşlarında
işte kalın kaşları kalın çerçeveli
gözlüğü ile tam tipi Klişe vitera pis
kafasıyla işaret etti koltuğa oturdum
başladım anlatmaya işte dedim ki
çarpıntılarının var
bu tahliye et nefessiz uyanıyorum işte
yerin altına inemiyorum göre çıkamıyorum
bakma bilemiyorum onu yapamıyorum bunu
yapalım falan böyle 10 dakika boyunca
anlatmış bittiğinde de şöyle gözlüğün
üzerinden bana bakarak dedi ki evladım
sağ reklamcı mısın bundan sonra Aslında
biraz daha bilimsel bir eş ister bulundu
O da şu an bozukluğu olduğunu söyledi
dedi bakın yapabileceğiniz iki şey var
bundan bir hızlı çıkış yolu var Sana bir
antidepresan yazarım iki haftada kendini
daha iyi hissetmeye başlarsın ya da dedi
Benimle bir terapi sürecine girer ve
bunun sonunda da kalıcı kazanımlar elde
edersiniz Ben de gözümü kadar ikincisini
seçtim gerçekten bir buçuk iki yıl süren
bir sürecin içine girdim ve gerçekten bu
süreci sonunda kendimi daha iyi şimdi
Önemli olan nokta şu sonra da
Farkediyorum bulurmu insanlarda iz
bırakın ödül alan
Bu gerçekten konuşturan aktif olmayan ne
kadar işin varsa Bu süreçten sonra
hayata geçirmiş o zaman da birşeyin
farkına var bizim yaratıcılığımızı
belediye iki tane şey var Bir tanesi
Allah vergisi potansiyeli Bununla ilgili
yapabileceğim hiçbir şey yok dünyaya
bununla geliyoruz ama ikincisi bu
potansiyeli hayata geçirme oranı
konusunda yapabileceğimiz çok fazla şey
var ve şunu neredeyse yüzdeyüz
kesinlikle söyleyebilirim ki hepimiz
gerçek yaratıcı potansiyelimizin altında
bir performans gösteriyoruz bunun içinde
elinde çok sağlam bir kanıt var Onu da
size göstereyim bugün video olacağız bu
balinayla
bu Mustafa
abone ol
bu molino balina
Sen bana bir gitti
O biraz önce buradaydı seviyorduk
ba ba
[Müzik]
he he
Ah ah süper süpermiş bu Leyla benim
kızım ve videoda Anlayacağınız üzere
masamızın üzerinde Balinalar yaşadığını
ve evinize zeminde Okyanus olduğunu
düşünüyor ve ben iyi bir Reklam yüzü
olduğu düşündüğüm nacizane ama böyle bir
hayal gücüne sahip değilim yani bunları
hayal edebilmek için çok güçlü bir
kimyasal kullanıyor olmam lazım Ve bunun
sizler için de geçerli olduğunu
düşünüyorum hepimiz kendimizi kendi
çocukluğumuzda kıyasladığımızda hayal
gücü anlamında yaratıcılık anlamında
oyunculuk anlamında eve gittiğimiz
hissederiz ve bunu neredeyse bir kader
güneşi yapıyoruz incelediğimizde şunu
görüyoruz bütün hayvanlar alemi
çocukluktan yetişkinliğe geçtiğinde de
bu patlasın çal oynasın keyifli bir
hayata devam ederken pis insanlar sanki
kadermiş gibi zaman içinde bu yürü hali
geride bu
10.30 gibi hissediyoruz bakın şöyle
birşey yapılmış gerçekten ilerleyen
yaşla yaratıcılığın azalması arasında
bir korelasyon var mı bu var mı diye
sayısız bilimsel araştırma yapılmış ve
ne kadar bağlantı buluşuyorsunuz 02
bağlantı bulunamamış Hatta bir
araştırmacı mahvoldu yakışıklı
uğraştığımız sürece yaratıcılığınız
gelişi yani diyor ki aslında yaşlandıkça
dahil olma ihtimali zaten gerçekten Bu
fiziksel bir gerçek olsaydı yani biz
Yaşımız ilerledikçe 79 getiriyor
olsaydık Picasso Guernica gibi bir eseri
55 yaşında hayata geçiremez de tolkien
Yüzüklerin Efendisi gibi fantastik
şaheseri 62 yaşında yazamaz the ya da
bir colangelo hayatının en büyük
eserlerinden anlamayabilirler genceli
kilisesini 88 yaşında tasarlanamaz
ilerleyen yaşla azalması fiziksel
Bu bir gerçek değilse o zaman bunun
sebebi ne olabilir Bir arkadaşım bunu
kendi tabiriyle Peter Pan sendromu
dediğimiz sendromu açılıyor diyor ki et
Akman kitabında diyor hikaye diyor
Büyümek istemeyen bir çocuğun hikayesi
değil bir hikaye büyükte nevrotik bir
yetişkine yani düşmanı Kaptan Kanca gibi
bir yetişkine dönmek istemeyen bir
çocuğun hikayesi dir yani diyor ki biz
nevrozu toplumdan ve kültürden zaman
içinde öğreniriz üç tane size hikaye
anlatacağım küçük hikaye bir aktarma
esnasında Havaalanı uçağı beklemek
koşuşturan küçük sevimli bir çocuk var
Çok eğleniyor belli ve bir süre böyle
devam ettikten sonra Uzaktan bir erkek
sesi duyuyorum diyorum diyor ki Can Can
koşma düşeceksin o anda çocuğun bütün
enerjisini neşesi gidiyor yalnız çöktüm
babası ol
mi Evet şimdi yanına doğru gidiyor cam
düşeceksin düşebilirsin bu ifadenin
içinde keskinlik Bak bu bir çocukta
hangi duyu yapılandırıyor olabilir başka
bir tane örnek vereceğim arkadaşım bir
eve yemeğe davet etti hem de küçük kızı
var masanın önünde komik deniz kabuğu
görüyor Diyor ki bak diyor Bulanık
tuttuğu zaman dalgaların sesini
duyabilirsiniz kız gerçekten
kullanılıyor sonra diyor ki
heyecanlandırdı anneanne diyor
dalgaların sesini duyuyor kadının cevabı
Saçmalama kızım Sadece deniz kabuğu kız
misafirim de utanmış biçimde ağlıyor e
sütlü kernekli odasına gidiyor bu
çocukta hangi Duygu yapılandırıyor aç
örnek daha eklemeyin Onun da bir kızı
var fakat çalışmak zorunda ecel erişti
çok bakıcı falan geliyor bir gece annesi
çok özlüyoruz ve hasta numarası yapıyor
bak
bu şöyle birinci anneyi çok önemli bir
toplantıdan çıkar kehanetler aşağıda
geliyor kızgın numara yaptığımı
anlayınca zıvanadan çıkıyor ve diyor ki
ben diyor bu işi kaybedersem suçlusu
sensin bu çocukta hangi duyguyu
yapılandırdığı suçluluk Şimdi size daha
güncel bir örnek vereyim bir beyin
fırtınasının ortasında sınız aklımıza
sivri bir fikir geldi ah diye arkadaş
olduğu için söylediğinizde bir tanesi
size dedi ki ya böyle bir fikir
müşteriye sorulur mu korku ikinci dedik
ya böyle saçma sapan olur gözünü seveyim
hem de o da üçüncüsü dedi ki istiyorsan
git sonuç müşteri ama Kaybedersen Senin
haberin olsun hangi duyguyu ateşlendi
suçluluk çocukluğumuzdan itibaren
içimizde yapılandıran bu negatif
duygular yetişkinliğe kadar peşimizi
bırakmaz bizi takip eder ve her anımızda
oldukça da artmıştır bu
Ama aramızda ki bu insanların bize
uyguladığı şey ne denir sansür Sen sudan
daha korkmuş bir şey var bu setleri
kendi içimizde yapılandırmaya başlarız
bir noktaya geldiğinizde değilsiniz ki
herkes saçmalama öyle şey mi olur
söylemeyiz bir o kalabalığın içinde o
Fikri işte bunları otosansür Ama bundan
daha korkunç bir şey var O da şu
bilinçaltında yüzen Cevher belinde bir
dolu fikir vardır içinizdeki bu negatif
duygular o kadar O istiyor ki o
fikirlerin bilinçaltından bilinci
çıkmasına bile izin vermez İşte bunlar
da biz kastrasyon dövüz teknolojide
travmayı t harfi ile sim geliyorlar
büyük de büyük travmaları küçükleri
küçük travmaları ve sembolize ediyor
hangisinin daha kolay çözüldüğünü
düşünüyorlar biliyor musunuz büyük
travmaları bir travmayla kastım nedir
taciz kayıp kazır gibi başınıza gelen
büyük olaylar küçüktür ama de
bu sefer bahsettiğim anektodlar daki
gibi ufak ufak küçük küçük olaylar şimdi
büyük Trabzon'u daha kolay çözülür Neden
biliyor musunuz Bir arabanın
kaportasında ki vurup gibi o kadar varis
ki güncel olaylarla o kadar rahat
ilişkilendirme biliyorsunuz pat diye
konunun merkezine biliyorsunuz küçük
travmalarda ise bu küçük küçük şeyler
dokunuşlar sizin ruhunuza bir Oya yavaş
yavaş işleniyor öyle bir noktaya
geliyorsunuz iki kişiliğinizi bir
parçası olarak kabul ediyorsunuz bunu
diyorsunuz ki Ben utangaç Facebook
dünyaya utangaç olarak gelen bebek var
mı diyorsunuz ki ben korkak dediğim gibi
bebek dünyaya korkak olarak gelebilir mi
Biz nevrozu öğreniyoruz kimden
öğreniyoruz toplumdan ve kültür
deniyoruz Peki sanat ve zanaat nedir bu
içimizde yapılan negatif duyguları bir
nebze olsun yaratıcı
bu dışında bırakabilmek için aslında
benimle beraber çalıştığım yaratıcı
insanları önerdiğim Jetta Şimdi biz
yaratıcı bir fikre ortaya koyar
yaşamıyoruz birbirinden tamamen bağımsız
bir birbirine tamamen zıt Hatta beynin
farklı noktalarını kullanan iki süreç
yaşıyoruz birincisi şu bir sanat
çözünürlüğünde e serbestliğinde o
Biricik fikir peşinde koşuyoruz ve bu
izin duygusal zekamızı kullanmayı
gerektiriyor ikinci şu bulduğumuz o
fikrin bir usta titizliğin de salgında
ve inceliğinde istiyoruz güvenebilmek Bu
da Analitik zeka gerektiriyor şimdi ilk
sürecin içine Analitik zeka girdiğinde
Biz Kabızlığa şaşırırız endişelerinizi
artıyor O bahsettiğim negatif duygular
alevleniyor ikinci sürecin içine de
duygusal zeka girdiğinde dağılıyoruz ve
daldığımızda da
ve tutarsız ve bütünlükten yoksun
fikirler ortaya koyu Dolayısıyla bu iki
süreci Keskin biçimde birbirinden ayırma
mevcudiyetini Ben adam gibi beraber
çalıştığım insanlara şunu öneriyorum
önce bir sanat yersiniz sanat yerken
Size gelen bir iş için fikir üretmeye
başlayacaksınız her şeyi yazın her şeyi
yazıyor Bu esnada zarar bahsettiğim o
otosansür mekanizmaları sonsuz aktif
olacak Size diyecek ki bu saçma bir
fikrim aptalca bitki bunu geç işte bu
noktada farkındalığının ayakta olması
lazım ve bu kafanızda konuşan sesleri
hiçe sayıp Aklımıza gelen her şeyi elde
etmemiz lazım İki hiçbir fikirde Derine
da anlayacaksınız peki hatırlayacağınız
içinde not ettiğiniz eğer o fikri
derinleştirmek şekillendirmeye
başlarsanız o zaman ona bağlanıyorsunuz
beni fikir üretme ihtimalimiz gittikçe
azalıyor ve bunların Son
ve suyunuzu çıkmalı doğal yorgunluğa
etmelisiniz İşte tam bu noktada bir ara
vermeniz gerekiyor burada fiziksel bir
ara vermeye yeterli değil gerçekten kafa
cayır uğraştığımız şeyler sizi
kopartacak bir meşgale nin içine
girmemiz gerekiyor çünkü Doğum gününüzde
başka bir insan olacaksın bak zanaat
yapacaksınız şimdi bu noktada sonsuz
soğukkanlı sonsuz Zalim ve objektif Bir
hakem gibi davranmanız gerekiyor
döneceksiniz ilk beyazını fikirlere
bakacaksınız işlemeye ve Size verilen
kısıtları uygun mu bu şekilde
şekillendirebilir misiniz diye düşünerek
dikkatli yapacaksınız Ondan sonra
titizlikle ve sabun ve işlemine
başlayacaksınız ve gerekirse ara benim
tekrar dönüp rafine edeceksiniz yani
ince ayar çekeceksiniz bunları yaptıktan
sonra ömrüm
bu bakacaksınız tam bunları da kendiniz
de dürüst ile diyalog gerçekleştirmemiz
gerekiyor istediğimiz şey karşınızda
bulunuyorum durmuyorsa da bütün bu
süreci baştan yaşayacak engelleyecek
enerji İçinizde bulmanız gerekiyor Bu
kolay değil oluşan tasyon istiyor
farkındalık istiyorsa Bunu istiyor Ve
tabii ki çok çalışma istiyor Yani
kestirme bir yol değil ama kestirme yolu
arayanlar her zaman dedesiyle iğnesine
ziyaret edelim Çok teşekkür ederim